bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
trois ans de prison ferme pour le
journaliste khaled dresny que pensez
vous de ce verdict bon c'est dur pour un
journaliste qui a un site d'internet en
ligne mais il faut quand même éclaircir
certains poids on efface un
enchevêtrement entre deux concepts qui
sont le journaliste et l'activiste et
l'est où les journalistes et les eaux
l'activiste les journalistes
l'information sacré alors que nous
savons bien que l'opinion est libre les
deux chefs d'accusation sont d'ordre
sécuritaire pas même d'ordre politique à
incitations attroupement armé
2 atteinte à l'unité nationale donc là
irak est finie pour les uns et n'est pas
fini pour les bascules la société
algérienne est divisée aujourd'hui il y
a une grande partie qui a accepté la
révolution la révolution a eu lieu
la preuve bouteflika n est plus
président
la preuve c'est premier ministre son
temps présent ahmed ouyahia magna qui se
mêlent les milliardaires confie algeria
aussi actuellement son temps présent je
cite aléas des dommages d'une part coûte
alors une révolution a eu lieu
les trois éléments qu on connais bien
maintenant de la situation
révolutionnaire ont eu lieu là la
radicalisation de l'opposition qui veut
le départ du régime
les défections c'est le pouvoir et la
position de l'armée l'armée a été à côté
du peuple alors une partie de la
population algérienne n'a pas accepté
sans hésiter révolutionnaire n'a pas
accepté que laraque
enfin veut continuer veut continuer
après le cofidis n'a évidemment c'est
très très affaiblie
monsieur riley de la reynie fait partie
de cette partie mais moi quand je vois
sa photo sur les épaules des
manifestants je vois aussi l'activiste
l'activiste politique c'est pour cela je
dirais un enchevêtrement très délicat
entre le journaliste et l'activiste
politique
donc pour vous c'est d'activistes
politiques a été condamné et non pas de
journalistes
oui absolument bon comme je dis lui la
cites sur internet un site d'information
sur internet mais si l'activité sur ses
positions
onetik et les les les dirigeants des
maléfices tomber les chefs des
manifestants on voit bien les magies
l'aï pris sur les épaules des
manifestants dont elle fait la politique
et il fait la politique massive sa
responsabilité est d'ailleurs ce sont
des rois la liberté de manifester est
toujours sacré à mes yeux mais mes
comédies une il fait partie de cette
partie qui n'a pas accepté que la
révolution a eu lieu que le changement a
eu lieu et il faut commencer le travail
maintenant donc il veut continuer une
deuxième vague et c'est une partie aussi
au sein de la social géré yen très très
très radicale très radicale parce que el
al a souvent des ce logo qui sont pas
applicables genre ne voulons pas une
un état militaire nous voulons un état
civil sont des concepts d'ordre
philosophique cette fois-ci faux prévaut
est vraiment chercher ces points le
militaire c'est quoi le civil donc cette
partie de la populiste opération
algérien continue veut encore et nos
révolutions mais cette nouvelle
révolution elle va viser quoi elle va
viser quoi je sais pas je ne sais pas on
va voir qu'est ce qui va se passer mais
je peux confirmer qu'une belle partie de
la population algérienne à accepter le
fait qu'une révolution a eu lieu une
révolution à gagner et tout à réaliser
tous ces objectifs à leur tête
boutaflika n'a pas eu ces quelques
mandats et ses premiers ministres sont
en prison ainsi que les corrompus rien
d'un sidaoui merci pour votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur du
centre arabe de recherche et d'analysé
politique et sociale merci